عدد ضحايا زلزال سوريا وتركيا يتخطى
الاثنى عشر الف قتيل فرحه كبيره بانقاذ
عائله سوريه كامله من تحت الانقاض وعرض
لقميص لرونالدو بمزاد لمساعده ضحايا زلزال
تركيا هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
في حصيله جديده لضحايا الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ارتفاع عدد قتلى الزلزال الذي ضرب
المنطقه الى اكثر من 9000 قتيل واصابه نحو
53 الف بجروح وفي كلمه له خلال تفاقده
موقع مركز الزلزال في ولايه قهرمان مرعش
اكد اردوغان ان حكومته ستنهي اعاده اعمار
المناطق المتضرره خلال عام واحد اما في
سوريا فاعلن المرصه السوريه لحقوق الانسان
ان حصيله الضحايا في عموم المناطق السوريه
وصلت الى
3135 على الاقل وصل استمرار عمليه البحث
عن ناجينه في البلدين
ومع تعثر دخول المساعدات الى شمال السوريه
كشف رئيس هيئه التفاوض في المعارضه
السوريه بدر جاموس عن تامين ادخال
المساعدات لمتضرر الزلزال من معابر
السلامه والراعي وباب الهوى شمال البلاد
بعد التواصل مع الحكومه التركيه جاموس دعا
عبر حسابه في تويتر الدول والمنظمات
الدوليه الى التحرك العاجل والفوري لنجده
المنكوبين في ريفي ادلب وحلب فيما حضرت
فرق الانقاذ في الشمال السوري من خطوره
الوضع مؤكده ان كل ساعه تاخير في ايصال
المساعدات الى المنطقه التي هزا الزلزال
تقابلها 50 حاله وفاه
وسط القصص الماساويه والمفكيه عقب الزلزال
المدمر في سوريا انتشرت فيديوهات عده في
السوشيال ميديا بثت الفرحه في قلوب
السوريين والعالم اجمع ففي فيديو جديد
نشره فريق ملهم السوري تم انقاذه عائله
كامله بعد اكثر من اربعين ساعه من عمليه
الانقاذ للدفاع المدني في شمال البلاد
فيما اظهر فيديو اخر انقاذ رجال الدفاع
المدني طفلا يدعى كرم من تحت الركام حيث
خرج وهو يضحك ويداعب الحاضرين من المنقذين
في رفيق ادلب
بعدما اثارت تنبؤاته ضجه واسعه في مواقع
التواصل عاد العالم والباحث الهولندي
المختص في الزلازل
لاثاره الجدل مجددا اذ كشف ان المنطقه
كلها تعيد التموضع والتشكل بعد الزلزال
العنيف الذي ضرب تركيا هوجر بيتس كشف في
تغريده جديده على حسابه في تويتر ان
الزلزال القوي الذي ضرب وسط تركيا تسبب في
حدوث تغيير كبير في توزيع الضغط في جميع
انحاء المنطقه ورافق ذلك نشاط زلزالي
وصولا الى فلسطين لافتا الى ان المنطقه
تعيد التموضع
وفي خبرنا الاخير اعلن اللاعب التركي
مريحه ديميرال انه سيتم بيع قميص النجم
البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو من المجموعه
الواقعه له في مزاد مشيرا الى ان الارباح
ستذهب الى اغاثه المتضررين من زلزال تركيا
دمار كتب عبر حسابه رسمي بموقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر قائلا انه تحدث مع
كريستيانو واخبره انه حزين جدا لما حدث في
تركيا واكد اللاعب التركي انه سيفعل ما في
وسعه لمساعده اولئك الذين دمرتم الكارثه
الطبيعيه